here's a tricky problem in how many
different ways can the letters of the
word football be arranged such that all
the vowels are always together we are
talking about the word football here
indirectly we have been asked for the
number of anagrams we can form using the
word football anagram is the word formed
by simply rearranging the letters of
another word here we're talking about
the word football but are we asked for
all possible anagrams of the word
football or are we given any condition
yes we have a condition the Wawel should
always be together the vowels of the
English alphabet are a e i o & u so
let's look at the word football letter
by letter the first letter is f not a
vowel the next two letters are oh and oh
is the vowel we have seen that whenever
we've seen such a condition where a few
letters are always together we consider
them as one element so let's not write
the O's here the next letter is T it's
not a vowel we write it next to F B is
also not a wobble a is a vowel so we
don't write it here the next two letters
are L and L is not a vowel we can write
them here the ones we have missed are oh
oh and a so we write the vowels together
here as the vowels always have to be
together we consider them as one element
so after this assumption how many
elements do we have in all one two three
four five and six six elements do you
remember the technique we used to solve
anagram problems we have to find the
number of anagrams possible for Mook as
there were four letters in all we wrote
four factorial first and then divided it
by two factorial as a letter was
repeated twice this is a super
interesting problem if you've understood
this concept of forming anagrams first
let's look at the six elements we have F
BLL and bubbles these six elements can
be arranged in six factorial ways and do
we have a repetition in these six yes
the element L is repeated twice the
other elements are distinct don't look
at the two ORS now don't forget this is
one element so if we are looking at
these six only two are repeated Oh Oh a
is different from each of these five
okay so as two elements are repeated we
divide six factorial by 2 factorial is
this our answer this would have been our
answer if the sixth element has just one
letter but it has three so with this we
also have to consider the arrangements
of these three letters FTB ll oo a is
different from FTB ll or a o or ft b ll
a oh oh now just focus on the sixth
element it has three letters out of
which two are repeated as it has three
letters we multiply these with three
factorial and as two are repeated we
divide this by two factorial this is our
answer these many anagrams of the word
football can be formed such that all its
vowels are always together
some of us I'm sure are still confused
let's understand this again this is the
first part of our answer six factorial
over 2 factorial this is arranging six
letters out of which two are identical
hence six factorial divided by 2
factorial and which were the six
elements one two three four five and six
and the letter L appears twice and this
is the other part of the answer where we
are only looking at the sixth element
which has three letters three factorial
ways in which we can arrange three
letters and we divided by 2 factorial as
two letters are repeated as a matter of
fact if we work the second part out we
get three what does 3 imply
for every case of the first part there
are two more possibilities of the second
if we look at this case for example we
will also have f DB ll o AO and f TB l
LA or o solving this should give it the
answer as 1080 ways
you